♪ DON'T YOU WORRY ABOUT A
THING.
>> Juan: IMPEACHMENT
MOMENTUM BUILDING FOR
DEMOCRATS.
A MAJORITY OF LAWMAKERS IN
THE HOUSE NOW SUPPORT TAKING
ACTION AGAINST THE
PRESIDENT.
THE MOVE BEING SEEN AS A
POLITICAL RISK BECAUSE AT
THE MOMENT POLLING SHOWS THE
MAJORITY OF AMERICANS DO NOT
SUPPORT IMPEACHMENT.
SPEAKER NANCY PELOSI AND
DEMOCRATS ARE STILL PRESSING
AHEAD.
>> THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN
ENGAGED IN A COVER-UP ALL
ALONG.
>> I THINK THERE ARE ANY
NUMBER OF POTENTIAL CRIMES
WHEN A PRESIDENT IS
SOLICITING FOREIGN
ASSISTANCE AGAIN.
>> DONALD TRUMP IS GOING TO
CHOKE ON THIS SUPPOSED
NOTHING BURGER.
HE WILL GO DOWN WITH THIS
SUPPOSED NOTHING BURGER IN
HIS THROAT BECAUSE WHAT IT
SHOWS IS REPEATED CONCERTED
PREMEDITATED CRIMINAL
CONDUCT.
>> Juan: SO, KATIE, THE
POLLING IS INTERESTING HERE.
WE HAVE A NEW POLITICAL
MORNING CONCEPT THEY HAVE
SUPPORT FOR IMPEACHMENT UP 7
POINTS IN THE LAST FEW DAYS.
IT'S NOW 43, 43.
WHAT'S INTERESTING TO ME BY
THE WAY IS LIKE 40% OF
INDEPENDENTS NOW SUPPORT IT
AND EVEN A 5% JUMP FROM 5%
TO 10% AMONG REPUBLICANS.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> Katie: WELL, FIRST I'M A
LITTLE NERVOUS ABOUT SENATOR
WHITEHOUSE SAYING A NOTHING
BURGER IS GOING TO GET STUCK
IN THE PRESIDENT'S THREAT.
A LITTLE WEIRD BLUMENTHAL
WEIRD WITH LANGUAGE AND
DESCRIPTION WITH WHAT THEY
THINK IS HAPPENING.
I THINK THE IDEA THAT
IMPEACHMENT IS NOW MOVING
FORWARD WITH NANCY PELOSI AT
THE HELM PROVES THAT SHE IS
NO LONGER IN CHARGE.
AOC IS IN CHARGE.
REPUBLICANS ARE RAISING
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS OFF OF
IMPEACHMENT.
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN IS
CELEBRATING SAYING THAT THEY
THINK NOW PRESIDENT TRUMP
WILL CERTAINLY WIN IN A
LANDSLIDE IN 20206789
PRESIDENT TRUMP NOW EVERY
TIME HE DOES A BRIEFING OR A
GAGGLE WITH REPORTERS, HE
PICKS OFF ALL OF THE THINGS
HE HAS BEEN WANTING TO DO.
GUN CONTROL, LEGISLATION, OR
REFORM.
HE WANTS TO DO, YOU KNOW,
ALL THESE OTHER ISSUES,
INFRASTRUCTURE, HEALTHCARE,
THE BUDGET, AND NOW HE IS
SAYING WE CAN'T GET THAT
DONE BECAUSE THE DEMOCRATS
WANT TO FOCUS ON THIS.
AND AMERICANS LOOK AT IT WHO
DON'T WANT IMPEACHMENT
ACCORDING TO ALL THE POLLING
WHICH HASN'T MOVED MUCH AND
SAYING I'M EITHER NOT GOING
TO VOTE FOR DEMOCRATS OR I'M
GOING TO SIT IT OUT OR, YOU
KNOW, MAYBE I WILL GO TO THE
REPUBLICAN SIDE BECAUSE THEY
WANT TO ACTUALLY GET THINGS
DONE WITH MY TAX MONEY AND
VOTES I HAVE GIVEN THEM FOR
THE POWER THEY HAVE IN THE
HOUSE.
>> Juan: JESSE, I NOTICED
TODAY THE PRESIDENT TWEETED
IF HE GETS IMPEACHED, THE
MARKETS ARE GOING TO TANK.
SO, I GUESS HE IS TRYING TO
HAVE SOME IMPACT ON WHAT HE
CONSIDER TO BE THE SHIFTING
SANDS OF PUBLIC OPINION WITH
LATEST POLL.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> WELL, I DON'T BELIEVE THE
POLL NUMBER ONE.
I HAVE A RASMUSSEN POLL.
VERY ACCURATE.
44% OF INDEPENDENTS.
SO I HAVE SEEN SOME
DIFFERENT OPINIONS ABOUT
THAT.
I'M NOT READY TO TAKE THAT
TO HEART.
BEFORE WE TALK ABOUT THAT
JUAN, I BROUGHT SOMETHING
FOR YOU.
>> Juan: OH, PLEASE.
>> BECAUSE NOW WE HAVE TO
DEAL WITH SOURCE
DOCUMENTATIONS ON THE SHOW.
>> Greg: YES.
>> Jesse: I HAVE FOUND FROM
1999-2,000 A TREATY WITH
UKRAINE SEARCHED BY BILL
CLINTON LEGAL ASSISTANCE AND
CRIMINAL MATTERS WHICH
BASICALLY ESTABLISHES A
RANGE OF COOPERATION BETWEEN
THE TWO GOVERNMENTS OF
UKRAINE AND THE UNITED
STATES ABOUT MAKING
TESTIMONY AVAILABLE, MAKING
PEOPLE AVAILABLE, MAKING
DOCUMENTS AND RECORDS
AVAILABLE AND ASSISTING IN
THE COOPERATION OF MUTUAL
CRIMINAL MATTERS.
AND THEY DON'T EVEN HAVE TO
BE CRIMINAL.
THEY CAN JUST BE
ALLEGATIONS.
SO, THERE IS A FIRM LEGAL
UNDER PINNING TO THE
REQUEST, THE
COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF TO A
COUNTRY DRY AN ALLY WHO WE
HAVE A TREATY WITH ABOUT
CRIMINAL PROCEDURE TO SAY
HEY, CAN YOU LOOK INTO SOME
POTENTIAL CORRUPTION
ALLEGATIONS INVOLVING A U.S.
CITIZEN?
NOW, IF YOU ARE GOING TO SAY
THAT BIDEN IS NOT, YOU KNOW,
UNDER THIS TREATY THAT MEANS
BECAUSE SEA POTENTIAL, YOU
KNOW, CANDIDATE AGAINST THE
PRESIDENT, SINCE HE IS A
POLITICAL OPPONENT IN AN
ELECTION SEASON HE CAN'T BE
INVESTIGATED THAT MEANS ANY
TIME THAT I'M ACCUSED OF A
CRIME OVERSEAS I CAN JUST
DECLARE I'M RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT AND THEN I CAN'T
BE PROSECUTED BY THE
GOVERNMENT?
>> Dana: UNDER THAT THEN TO
YOUR POINT ABOUT THE OBAMA
TEAM AND HILLARY CLINTON
TEAM UNDER THAT SAME TREATY
ASKING FOR UKRAINE HELP TO
INVESTIGATE DONALD TRUMP
WOULD FIT UNDERNEATH THE
SAME TREATY.
>> Jesse: IF THAT IS AN
INVESTIGATION THAT IS A
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
INVESTIGATION, THAT DOES NOT
FALL UNDER CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION BECAUSE THAT'S
WHAT THAT WAS UNDER BARACK
OBAMA.
AND, REMEMBER, THERE WERE NO
BASIS FOR THOSE INQUIRIES,
EITHER.
IF YOU ARE GOING TO SAY THAT
THAT'S OKAY, THEN WHAT TRUMP
IS OKAY, TOO.
>> Juan: OKAY, OKAY.
YOU WIN.
I GIVE UP.
GREG,Y GIVE UP WITH YOU.
I WANT TO ASK YOU SOMETHING.
WHAT DOES THE RIGHT DO RIGHT
NOW?
DO THEY HAVE TO CLOSE THEIR
EYES, THEIR EARS?
DO THEY HAVE TO TURN THE
BLANKET OVER THEIR HEAD AND
SAY TRUMP DID NOTHING WRONG?
>> Greg: NO ONE IS DOING
THAT.
WHAT WE ARE DOING AND I
COUNT MYSELF AS ONE OF THEM
IS STICKING TO THE FACTS.
THE POLLS REFLECT THAT THE
PUBLIC DOES NOT WANT
IMPEACHMENT.
THAT MEANS THE MEDIA NEEDS
TO GET TO WORK AND CHANGE
THEIR MINDS.
WHICH IS WHAT THEY ARE
DOING.
MY JOB AND THE JOB OF A ROT
OF PEOPLE IS TO EXPOSE HOW
OBVIOUS THE MEDIA ARE IN
SHAPING THE ENVIRONMENT TO
BENEFIT THE DEMOCRATS.
WHAT THEY ARE WILLING TO DO
OVER A CASUAL PHONE CALL
BECAUSE THEY HAVEN'T
RECOVERED FROM 2016, IS
RISKING THE SOCIAL COHESION
OF A COUNTRY.
THE MEDIA DOESN'T CARE ABOUT
THAT BECAUSE THIS IS THE
PROFIT MODEL.
DIVISION IS THEIR PROFIT
MODEL, IT'S A STRATEGY.
SO THEY ARE WILLING TO UPEND
AN ECONOMY, STOP A PEACEFUL
PROSPEROUS NATION IN ITS
TRACKS BECAUSE THEY CAN'T
GET OVER THE FACT THAT TRUMP
WON.
IN FACT, THEY ARE IMPEACHING